look who showed up at our office today
being totally responsible dude you go
and take a big breath of that you'll
pass out every couple weeks we get a
shipment of food from flexpro meals and
it comes with dry ice I just remember
putting dry ice and water and having a
great time correct me if I'm wrong but
isn't it would you call this vapor I
mean it's not smoke it's not steam if it
falls because it's colder than the air
around it making it less buoyant than
the air so it's sink this is just water
vapor is that sure it's carbon dioxide
that's come out of the dry ice right I
love heard this is water vapor that
we're saying that's what we did we had a
great time and then we put some soap in
there and those great times just got
even better this open here amid funky
bubbles
[Music]
oh my gosh so everyone here we've been
talking we're trying to come up with a
more consistent output of videos today
is kind of like in our first day where
we're trying to wrap our heads around
the whole can we come up with an idea
within one day because that's kind of
what we have to do if we want to keep
pumping out videos frequently then today
you're gonna brainstorm right now I
don't know what ideas we might come up
with but I know they have to be funny
well they don't have to be funny but I
want them to be funny there's one of
these is over here right here
[Music]
these guys are great man dude does it
hurt - laughs it hurts so bad - laughs -
I'm like sweating there's annoying stuff
happening - the more Kombat characters
or the noise to normal penis and then
they intervene and then the Mortal
Kombat character be exact okay I have
one question for you we need your help
all right what are your pet peeves what
just makes you go poop examples examples
would be like dude the guy who's
completely capable of walking or
something parks in the handicap spot
looking up all of the fatalities and
start picking out like the best one
that's exactly
[Music]
it's like Slammys a refresh or something
about dry ice it's like so simply
interesting yeah
is this the birth of a viral internet
trend risky
it's going around my finger it's not
popping just going around ready
[Music]
it was heard him coming to do this this
this proves that this is the perfect one
cuz it's like what we're talking about
of like stuff that everyone knows but in
the video game world and it's action
amos comedy boom dude that would like
that ten minutes that was very important
in its you know their next video idea
it's gonna be more combat real-life
fatalities in real life eight hours in
real life Chloe the fatalities are
happening to the people who annoy you
universal annoyances like set yeah
universal annoyance I think that's the
key word Universal Alliance is there you
go but they need to be so clear-cut
where you go oh I hate when people do
yes you don't need everything twice
again
they do that let's list out all the
annoying things that you doesn't say
like I don't want people to think that
word we're saying oreillons this finds
everything you know I think if we frame
it in the right way it'll it'll be okay
violence is a solution which is
definitely not what we're treating is
like
[Music]
it's so bad there you know it has a
tingly feeling like soda
Grenn are you just trying to get us eat
so err I'm doing it like seriously trip
I'm not actually eating it just poke it
has a weird sensation on your tongue it
kind of is like the sensation of like
drinking soda am i drinking so that
Ren's actually kind of right this is the
new merchant design just dry ice and
warm water and this naturally happens
science still the board and it's moved
and I nearly fell over so you're all the
way
[Applause]
- oh hey let me let me okay I waited
over two years alright yeah so the door
games are a bit weird you guys put your
thumb there and then pull it from there
okay well in I mean you know what
freaked me out there it was the
acceleration it was the there's a
massive truck you just press the door
button or button looks like a she's
tracking other cars in real time you did
not need to put that much like self
erection home back so there's two things
to autopilot one is adaptive cruise
control in the second level of that is
actually Lane Assist so if I turn this
on right now it is fully on and I'm
supposed to have my hands on the
steering wheel yeah but you don't have
to okay like this is obviously very
responsible for how unsafe we are right
now like look at look at this working I
am totally responsible driving simulator
I've seen how bad my driving gets when
I'm distracted by a camera like I do not
do much it works quite well
okay now go up and it should catch
[Music]
[Laughter]
in the description channel why we know